[Music]
tis the season for video games e3 is
upon us and the rumors are already
spinning we'll be covering all the big
press conferences and all the hottest
games so make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss a thing in the meantime
here's what you can expect during
ubisoft's III 2017 press conference
[Music]
Ubisoft's flagship franchise assassin's
creed is scheduled to make a return
sometime this year and it's reportedly
called origins but you already knew that
because it leaked it looks like it will
also take place in Egypt but you already
knew that too because it leaked here's a
photo you've probably already seen
because it leaked as well considering
this would be the earliest time period
an assassin's Creed game has taken place
origins will most likely serve as a
prequel to the entire series back in
January 2016
Kotaku reported on a leak that it will
revamp the series and have a Witcher
feel according to the leak you will play
as an escaped slave horseback riding
will return and it will be roughly three
times the size of Black Flag Ubisoft
hasn't officially commented on any of
this but the image they released pretty
much confirms that we will find out more
at e3 you can feel that we are creeping
towards the edge
we already got a sneak peek at Far Cry 5
a couple weeks ago but hopefully we will
see the game in action at e3 far cry 5
looks like it will share some
similarities with its predecessor such
as an open world filled with vehicles
the pilot and guns to shoot but this is
the first Far Cry game to take place in
the United States
more specifically the fictional hope
County Montana far cry 5 will allow you
to create your own character team-up
with a buddy and wage war against a
radical colt named Eden's gate this will
also be the first Far Cry will you'll be
able to pilot airplanes far cry 5 is
scheduled to release February 27th 2018
for Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC so it
would make sense for Ubisoft to show us
more at e3 if I am NOT THERE shun
then I must be the wolf
[Music]
Tom I'm standing outside where a
vigilante has declared war on crime in
South Park security camera footage
showed a young person partying people's
faces on their balls it was just
terrifying you ain't never heard a fart
like this man the kick just started
farting on people it was out of nowhere
man how long before he or she kills an
innocent person the sequel to 2014 South
Park stick of truth should also make an
appearance at e3 originally slated for a
2016 release date the fractured but
whole has been delayed twice but fans
should expect to get their hands on the
game in October the fractured but whole
shifts its focus from fantasy tropes to
superhero wands oh you want civil war
ease how would you watch yeah dude Civil
War you oh you get at Cartman's infamous
superhero character the [ __ ] will return
and lead a superhero Civil War the
gameplay this time around is closer to
tactical RPGs like XCOM or Fire Emblem
then a turn-based RPG like the first I
didn't want to have to do this but you
leave me no choice did I just hear
someone use a microaggression
start your engines because it sounds
like the follow-up to Ubisoft's
ambitious open-world racing game the
crew will make it appearance the crew
too is expected to release within the
next 12 months but apart from a logo we
haven't seen anything 2014's the crew
kind of fell flat we gave it a 5 so
here's hoping the crew too will fare
better this time around
it sounds like Ubisoft have some big
plans for the Nintendo switch
apart from steep Rayman legends the
definitive edition and Just Dance coming
to the hybrid console we might also see
the long rumored Mario and Rabbids
crossover the game looks to be called
Mario Rabbids Kingdom battle and it
looks to have Rabbids dressed up as
peach taking selfies but once again we
don't know much about this game either
I'd say there's a pretty good chance
we'll see most of these games during e3
but there's still a couple games I'm
holding out for the first is Splinter
Cell we haven't seen a new game in the
franchise since 2013 with the excellent
blacklist
according to neogaf user crossing Eden
we could see a new splinter cell game
and maybe with michael ironside
reprising his role as sam fisher and
while we're at it give us an update on
that Splinter Cell movie that was teased
in chaos theory back in 2005 come on
seriously Ubisoft but you won't
the whole story until you've seen the
movie Paramount Pictures presents Tom
Clancy's Splinter Cell the movie coming
soon only to theaters and of course it
wouldn't be a ubisoft press conference
without me crossing my fingers and
praying to the videogame gods that we
finally see Beyond Good and Evil 2 the
sequel was first revealed back in 2008
and since then we haven't really seen
anything apart from some leaked footage
unfortunately we reported last month
that it will most likely not appear at
e3 however the game will be shown
sometime this year
the game's director posted on Instagram
not sure that III would be the best
place to showcase Beyond Good and Evil
but we're working on the game so
sometime this year you should hear about
it hopefully we will at least get a
little tease during the press conference
what are you hoping to see d3 this year
we are releasing videos like these every
day for each of the press conferences so
make sure to keep checking back and if
you want your III news on the go then
make sure to download the game spot now
app it's fast its sleek and of course
it's free it's the best way to check the
top 10 stories of the day and with that
thanks for watching
[Music]